madame la ministre monsieur le
Commissaire chers collègues la formation
professionnelle retrouve enfin ces
lettres de noblesse avec cette année
européenne des compétences bien sûr mais
surtout avec les grands changements que
nous opérons pour réindustrialiser notre
continent et pour créer les métiers de
la transition écologique nous avons
besoin de nouvelles compétences dans le
bâtiment dans le numérique dans le
tourisme dans l'industrie dans l'énergie
et le transport partout il y a des
opportunités de carrière valorisantes
pour les jeunes pour cela il faut que
les entreprises s'engagent dans le
mentorat et dans les stages rémunérés il
faut aussi se saisir plus largement des
opportunités d'Erasmus qui rappelons-le
est ouvert à l'apprentissage et aux
formations professionnelles pour mieux
partager nos compétences européennes et
parce que les bassins d'emploi sont d'un
côté et de l'autre de nos frontières
européennes
enfin nous comptons bien sûr sur vous
monsieur le Commissaire pour que cette
année de compétences soit faite de
réalisation concrète merci beaucoup